tesla stocks soared on monday august
31st
after a stock split lifting elon musk's
net worth to 102.9 billion dollars
forbes calculates that he is now the
fifth centi billionaire in the world
as well as the fifth richest person in
the world
[Music]
musk's net worth has quadrupled since
mid-march
when he ranked number 31 on forbes
world's billionaires list
he's now just behind facebook's mark
zuckerberg
who is worth 108 billion dollars
musk owns 21 of tesla but has pledged
more than half his stake as collateral
for personal loans
forbes applies a discount to his pledged
shares to account for the loans
but all of this really doesn't matter to
musk the 49 year old serial entrepreneur
said he's indifferent to his standing on
the forbes list of billionaires
in an email to forbes regarding his net
worth in july
musk says i really couldn't care less
these numbers rise and fall but what
really matters is making great products
that people love
[Music]
you